Katrina Perry what was the origin of
your book in America well I've been a
foreign correspondent here for the last
four years for the national public
broadcaster of Ireland RTE and I had
seen and witnessed some really amazing
things during my time here and there is
a tradition with predecessors that
there's always a book guide of us
because in Ireland where you know we
have a great affinity to America and to
what goes on here so people always want
to hear about what's behind the the
correspondents life experience now I
hadn't intended to do that until I was
finished my time here but given what
happened in last year's presidential
election there was just such massive
interest and the Irish American
community here but also at home in
Ireland in just what had happened what
had gone on the question I think many
Americans are asking themselves as well
I mean last year was really quite
extraordinary and so has this year been
so I was approached by publisher to
write the kind of sort of behind the
scenes but also just a bit of an
explainer type guides as to what was so
unique about the 2016 election campaign
what's going on in America right now
that leads the campaign to be what it
was and to kind of help people
understand that it's not all black and
white here politics aren't just red and
blue how many Americans living in the
United States have Irish roots it's it's
estimated somewhere according to census
figure it's between thirty and forty
million Irish Americans so massive
number a huge Irish diaspora all around
the world but of course mostly here in
the US I mean you'd be doing well to
find a family in Ireland who doesn't
have an aunt an uncle a sister brother a
cousin or a great aunt or great uncle
who has moved to this country set up
home often fall in love with an American
and never come back to Ireland and of
course historically it was through our
great famine and through looking for
employment and when things weren't great
on the island of Ireland that they came
over here so there's a huge connection
between the two countries and the two
peoples close to five million people in
the Republic of Ireland 26 counties
what's the big difference that you've
noticed between
in Ireland being an Irishman and the
United States Wow
we need a five hour special frying I
think and I mean they they're just two
totally different countries you can't
really compare them I mean primarily
starting from the point of view of scale
Ireland you know I'm a very proud Irish
person but it's a small country very
sparsely populated and we just don't
have the scale that there would be here
in the US either in terms of employment
opportunities for people or just
diversity either I mean purely in terms
of climates in this country you can have
one part of the country bathing in
sunshine and oh there's buried under
feet of snow we wouldn't have that in
Ireland either and you know I suppose
the people are probably quite similar
and that maybe does come from the fact
that so many have Irish heritage in that
I found Americans to be extremely
welcoming and friendly and open and
p'lice very well mannered
and particularly here in Washington DC I
mean I arrived not knowing anyone and I
was really wrapped into the community at
the Irish community but also the general
American community so and you know but I
mean gosh if we were to go into all the
different we'd be here all day
what about I mean friends did you say in
our in your book that there are some 44
million immigrants in the United States
making it the largest immigrant country
in the world what about in Ireland would
we see a lot of diversity in Ireland in
recent times yes and you'll have heard
of the Celtic Tiger so when we were
booming at that point we had a lot of
immigrants coming to Ireland from other
countries from mostly from Africa and
Eastern Europe many of them have made
Ireland their home and stayed we went
through a recession and during that
period many people would have gone back
to where they were from or a third
country and because our employment
opportunities just weren't there we have
turned a corner and things are improving
in Ireland and our economy is back in a
healthy position again and but we would
have a much narrower history with
immigration we've traditionally been a
nation of immigrants
and so we're only now sort of seeing the
cycling through of - where you have
people who are born in Ireland but of
parents from somewhere else you know
that's a relatively new phenomenon on
the scale that it's on at the moment can
you explain this to Americans that the
prime minister or the t-shirt cause you
call him in Ireland is a gay man given
the nature of the Catholic Church and
their attitude in some cases toward
homosexuals how did that happen and what
impact is it had well firstly I think
that maybe the view that people have of
Ireland in America particularly in some
poor parts of the Irish American
community would be far more conservative
than the Ireland that I'm from actually
is and we were the first country in the
world to approve same-sex marriage by a
vote of the people by referendum so that
just shows you something and I think the
fact that our tea shop is a gay man is
irrelevant and he he was elected through
a system within his own party so not
kind of by the people as such and people
would have her like elected him within
that vinegar party based on him as an
individual and you know what they viewed
his good policies to be again from
within that political party so and you
know I it made headlines all around the
world like including here it was in many
of the newspapers and on the television
networks that a gay man who's also one
of his parents is an immigrant himself
his father's from India and but you know
I think in a modern Ireland that's kind
of irrelevant he's just an Irish man who
happened to make his way up to the top
of his political party so who did you
write this book for so this book was
written primarily for I suppose an
outside of America audience for an Irish
audience or a Western European audience
and who traditionally would probably
align maybe with the Democratic Party
many of whom would have been Hillary
Clinton supporters and just really
struggled to understand how someone like
Donald Trump not a traditional
politician
could have really caught the zeitgeist
in the way that he did and what was
going on in American life and in
American politics to result in the
results that we've seen and but it's
also I think useful for people in
America as well who maybe are used to
living within certain communities and
you know of course the media here is
quite polarized at the moment so people
are in a self confirming media bubble
whereas this sort of set size may be a
different viewpoint and the people
hadn't seen before seeing your book that
the United States media doesn't operate
like it does in Ireland or Europe
because of a code of conduct tell us the
difference well so where I work RTE is
the public broadcaster it's it's part
funded by a license fee which everyone
on the island of Ireland has to pay if
you own a television you have to pay the
TV licence fee we also get some
commercial funding but that is our
primary income so that means that you
have to be neutral and objective you
can't favor one party or another when
it's an election season literally the
amount of time that each candidate
Gatsas is monitored on a stopwatch
to make sure that everything is fair and
that no-one's biased no one's taking one
agenda or another and for me that's been
very different to notice here in America
particularly their television networks
are so to the left or to the right and
whatever anyone from the other side does
is almost automatically bad and whatever
anything anyone does from their side is
almost automatically good so we don't
have that we leave it up to the people
to the voters to decide and come to
their own conclusion and and so in RTE
that's actually regulated by law and
then we would have the nuj the National
Union of Journalists code of conduct a
code of ethics as well that you you're
not you know you can't have a partisan
opinion on things particularly in
elections so four years in the United
States and you obviously travel for this
book where did you go all over the place
I was I was trying to hit all 50 states
but I got to about 44 and this book
specifically though focuses mostly on
the Appalachian region and
continuing on up into Wisconsin Michigan
including Texas as well because
obviously the border was such a big
issue in the campaign and but it mostly
focuses on those states that Donald
Trump specifically targeted the swing
states who you know maybe people thought
we're going to lean democratic honest we
know didn't and it's really about
meeting the people in those states
I mean we're well aware of the sort of
core base Donald Trump fo sure that we
see all the time but this is about the
more swing voter middle-of-the-road
independent voter and what motivated
them perhaps after voting democratic for
decades to switch and suddenly vote not
even for the Republican Party but
specifically for Donald Trump as an
individual you right near the end of the
book this meeting some of those voters
realizing that they have justifiable
reasons for being attracted to Trump and
remaining attracted to him despite
actions that others consider intolerable
or scandalous is key to understanding
the Trump phenomenon a little better how
long did it take you to get to that
conclusion lots of traveling I think
because you know as a journalist you
can't come to any conclusions based on
one two three four five people you meet
you've got you've got to get the
evidence over a long period of time but
what struck me really was you know
people view Donald Trump almost as an
ala carte candidates and there are
certain things that he said or did that
they really didn't like but there were
certain things that he said or did that
they really loved and they were prepared
to ignore other parts of him and what he
stood for for that one bit that spoke to
them and primarily that was around
economic improvement around jobs around
just feeling listened to and care
debates which I thought was very
interesting and instructive for other
politicians not just here in America but
around the world that you know you
ignore voters and their needs at your
peril and you can't take anything for
granted
in the early part of your book you wrote
this it was the one and only time in my
life where I have been in sole
possession of all of the fact
of a story and can see how it played out
across the media from the that vantage
point explain that well you are talking
about their data preface yeah that's me
referring to my interaction in the Oval
Office with President Trump and which
happened last June when the president
was making a call to our new t-shirt Lee
over at Kerr and to congratulate him and
anyway the president called me up to the
resolute desk and said a few words but
in a rug videos of those I mean it made
quite a bit of news country so let's run
this and then you can further explain it
what do you think find that I've seen
that video so many times now and so what
I was young men about knowing all the
facts of the story was I that incident
as it happened at the time was you know
whatever it is 15 20 seconds and I went
on about my business as the journalist
does and but it was in the next 24 to 48
hours that it just went completely as
they say viral right around the world
and that was extraordinary and you know
I mean the moment itself I described at
the time and I still describe it as a
bizarre moment it was not in protocol
perhaps but we know from this president
that he does things his way and he rips
up Brill books he did it throughout the
campaign and he's done it throughout the
presidency and does it his way so I mean
I've been in the Oval Office plenty of
times as other reporters and
correspondents have and usually when the
president is on a call with the foreign
leader like that you know they're
engaged in the call they're not
involving anyone else particularly a
member of the media so you know it was a
surprise when he sort of called me over
but he's the president of the United
States and you're in the Oval Office so
if he says you know who are you come
over here you sort of don't really have
an option but to do excuse me but to do
that so what what was it like though use
I think you say you had over a hundred
requests for interviews Oh probably even
more I mean I I had I had requests from
you know all the major networks and
newspapers and newsmen
seems in this country in Ireland in the
UK in Australia Japan Nigeria all across
Europe pretty much any country who can
name which was bizarre I mean though it
was interesting for me as a journalist
to be inside the story like that and to
see how it feels for someone who is
inside a story when you have all of
these requests for interviews and you
know people you're not a very good
journalist if people don't have your
phone number so a lot of people have my
phone number it's so I had to turn my
phone off for a while which again as the
journalist is a pretty remarkable thing
to do people were reaching out through
Twitter through Instagram through
Facebook through any possible way they
thought they could get hold of me and
and I at the time just decided I wasn't
actually doing any interviews about it
because and I was amazed at how
polarized that event became so it was
claimed by anti-trump people as meaning
one thing and it was claimed as
pro-trump people as meaning something
else and I just saw it as a working
journalist and as I say as someone who
has to be neutral and objective at all
times anything I would say about that
would be taken to feed one narrative or
another and ultimately I would be the
loser in that situation because it's so
divided in this country right now that
you were gonna say something that was
going to upset and offend my of amounts
of people so and you know definitely one
of the most extraordinary periods in my
life I have to say you know to be
sitting in your office and look up at
all the TV screens be at CNN Fox News
whatever and they're all playing that
video on loop and then have panels of
people discussing how I must have felt
what was going through my mind and you
know the laughter on the clip there is
actually not me that's someone else in
the room so you know they're you know if
people just said oh you know I shouldn't
have been wearing a red dress I didn't
know how to take a compliment I should
have said thank you you know other
people been saying
you know people say the presence means
the media he's being nice to this person
or he was being sexist and demeaning to
this person so it's just the full range
it seemed to bring out the full range of
opinions and emotions in people around
the world how often when you watch what
people were saying was in your mind at
the time did you say that's not true
I wasn't thinking anything like that
almost all of us that's a you know I
mean I'm a journalist who's been around
the president as president and his
candidate for a long time and he you
know he makes his own rules he does his
own his own things so for something out
of the ordinary to happen in the Oval
Office I didn't pass too much heed of us
at the time I was more concerned that my
deadline was a narrow furred from then I
had to rush to my live point you know
back in Ireland the fact that the
president and was on this call to our
new t-shirt was quite big news what
would they be discussing you know this
obviously a lot of hot topics between
the two countries
tax reform immigration so on so this was
a big they happened the the mere fact of
the phone call was the big deal in
Ireland so that's really all I was
concerned about and you know upon
leaving the oval office with the other
members of the press pack and with some
of the White House aides as well we were
kind of like oh that was that was large
that was a bit bizarre you know and off
we went and I actually went to a
Nationals baseball game that night with
some friends they were playing the Cubs
here in 10:00 at Nats park and you know
so you're engrossed in the game we're
not looking at your phone right and I
came out back into an area with a good
phone signal and that's when my phone
had just almost exploded really and then
I thought okay this is this is a bigger
deal than I initially anticipated when
did you know that you were going to be
called back to Ireland to rté to be an
anchor and just a base just as maybe
November and of October November and
yeah end of October and so we wrote
eight foreign correspondents here to the
US so
we do four-year terms so my four years
were coming to an end and he faced that
question of what am I going to do next
you know and so I hadn't really
considered being an anchor before I love
being a debate in the field so I just
got a phone call from the boss one day
saying oh we need you to come home and
take over the main evening news in
Ireland which I'll be co-anchoring with
another woman it's the first time there
will be two female anchors in Ireland on
the an RTE news bulletin so one hour
Monday to Friday every evening at 6 p.m.
1 p.m. Eastern people can chew in online
watch if they want to yeah so that's my
my next step really so to be very
different to what I've been doing here
in the US for the last four years we're
recording this at the end of 2017 when
is your first day as the anchor as
co-anchor it will be the 8th of January
so I'm kind of leaving here and then two
days later I start the new job back in
Ireland so no rest for the wicked they
say I count in your book that you went
that you wrote about 11 states that you
went to I don't know if you can do this
or not but I'd like to go through the
list and just get you would come back to
any of it but get you just to give us
something that you remember from each of
those states starting with Ohio Wow okay
and Ohio Ohio
I remember being beautiful actually
which is not something usually hear
about Ohio and you know that's it was
the stunning stunning Vista there but I
do remember being surprised and this is
not unique to Ohio but to the levels of
poverty in some parts of the United
States and particularly in high in Ohio
just how drugs have run ravaged through
parts of that space and you know don't
don't a dude a in the health State
because I really liked Ohio and had
great food there great chili but you
know I think if you don't travel through
the United States and as an outsider if
you just go to the big cities on your
holidays you don't see what's really
going on in
middle and you don't fully understand
the United States and you see small
communities in in Ohio and you know
heroin fentanyl have just taken a grip
there that's extraordinary mind-boggling
and people there are just crying out for
health but when you go into these
communities as an outsider they tell you
their stories frequently because you
know they they need help they need
assistance there is a story on the front
of the Washington Post one day about a
County Coroner having to bring in a
refrigerated shipping container such was
the number of dead bodies they were
going to find over the weekend from drug
overdoses I mean it's very difficult to
square that scenario with the United
States being one of the wealthiest
countries in the world and yet you have
some small communities that you know
they're doing everything they can for
sure but they just need help let me jump
all the way from Ohio down to Texas and
I know you were down in the McAllen area
and you talked to a border agent what
did you learn from that talking to the
border agent was very insightful
actually and because you see a different
view of things when you talk to those
guys who are patrolling the border every
day and every night I mean there is a
humanitarian story there for sure and we
have a similar situation in Europe with
refugees coming from Syria and parts of
Africa but the the humanitarian
situation in Texas is heartbreaking I
mean when people walk with literally the
clothes on their back and small children
for a month
sleeping on the sides of mountains and
whatever seek a better life and they're
coming across the border and then you
know the conditions they're facing and
the all of that that's ahead of them is
heartbreaking but then you talk to these
border agents who talk about the the
criminal element the Coyotes as they're
called who are smuggling in these people
who are smuggling in drugs and guns and
interestingly they said it was a two-way
street as well there are drugs and guns
coming out of the US across into Mexico
as well and they feel overwhelmed
you know and I know that President Trump
has upped the numbers of funding and and
border guards this year so things are
probably maybe a little better than when
I was there last year but it's really
it's a scary enough situation than there
at times I mean we were told not to be
near the Rio Grande as dusk was falling
and of course being TV journalists we
had to go and get the good pictures to
tell the story we were telling about the
border crossings and all of that and we
went to this one part of the Rio Grande
and there were shell casings like on the
riverbank
there was one flip-flop sticking in the
mud where was the other flip-flop there
were barefoot footprints of people who'd
come through there and obviously some
sort of gun battle and and you know just
what's going on Dan there are daily
nightly you know is it's it's a
situation that doesn't need to be
addressed what is this what are the aged
the agent think of the idea of building
a wall Toto is absolutely bonkers and
you know said there's obviously already
a wall or fence along one third of the
border as it is and but the agents that
I spoke to said it's not it wouldn't
help at all and we saw you know General
John Kelly when he was doing his
confirmation hearing last January to be
Department of Homeland Security
Secretary as he was initially saying the
same thing that walls don't do anything
because people are so determined to
either make a better life for themselves
or these gangs smuggling in drugs and
guns that they will tunnel under them
they will build over them they'll find a
way somehow and the border agents were
not necessarily in favor of that they
more were in favor of a virtual wall as
such so more funding for guards more
funding for immigration courts speeding
up that process and more equipment for
them to have to help patrol the border
area and but yeah very few people were
in favor of actually building a wall
that they thought that that would solve
anything let's go back all the way up
north to your most northern state that
you well actually you're in Wisconsin
but Massachusetts
and that's a famous Irish connected
state why were you why did you write
about that I wrote about that because
people at home were interested in
hearing about how Irish Americans had
voted because there would be a
traditional viewpoint that Irish people
and in fact many people in the western
part of Europe in particular would align
themselves with Democrats you know
harking back to the JFK ear and so on
and but it that's actually not true
Irish Americans and you learn that very
quickly upon living here that you know
Irish Americans are voters like any
other voters some of them are Democrats
some of them are Republicans many of
them favored Donald Trump many of them
are still quite conservative voters so
they would favor the Republican Party in
particular and in this instance Donald
Trump because of his positions on
certain things to do with family
abortion and so on a smaller government
lower taxes these kind of things so
that's really why Massachusetts is in
there I mean I've see it wasn't it
didn't help him in the overall election
but it's just my way of understanding
how our American voters think but you
did talk and that chapter about
immigrants and then you quote a man
named Louis Murray is a proud Irish
American who was Lewis Murray yeah Lou
Murray is the guy I met actually at the
originally at the convention and we
stayed in touch but he is a guy whose
heritage is Irish Americans weeds not
actually he wasn't born in Ireland
himself but he still has plenty of
cousins and family members there in Cork
and carried that he goes back to visit
but he was all in for Donald Trump you
know on a local organizing committee and
all of that and he really sort of is a
case study as such of Irish Americans
who really were in favor of this message
that Donald Trump was selling but also
the wider Republican Party message of
smaller government lower taxation more
conservative family value viewpoints
during the trial they were described as
homegrown terrorists who had come to
hate the United States who you're
talking about there that's the tsarnaev
brothers yeah that was them another
story that I reported on during my time
here I've seen osh connected to the
election but
and the the Boston Marathon bombing
Boston is one of those cities that you
know kind of almost feels like it's part
of Ireland I actually studied in Boston
University myself for a while back in
the day so and the bombing of that
marathon was something that really
resonated with people there is a quote
in that on that same chapter where
you're talking about President Obama and
you say he didn't do anything for the
Irish so he would be there would be that
viewpoint in terms of actually that was
Lou's quote yeah that wasn't me but that
but that was his quote if you and people
expect him to do something for the Irish
no no I mean he's a preppy Pilar the
presidents of America not of Ireland but
I suppose there would be a sense among
some Irish Americans that and there
would be movements to do with
immigration reform that would be an
issue that we would care about and also
in terms of tax reform many
multinational US companies are based in
Ireland creating a lot of jobs there
there are a lot of Irish companies in
America as well employing a lot of
people here too but I think Lou's point
there about Obama not doing anything for
the Irish what was to do with the
immigration situation you know there are
many again it's no is counting this but
there are estimated to be about 50,000
illegal or undocumented Irish people in
the US so there's always that hope from
their parents and family members back in
Ireland that there'll be some sort of
legislation to help normalize their
status so lose points there is probably
getting at us I think at the front and
the back of your book you have -
pictures - photographs I want to put
both of them up on the screen here's the
first one where is that and why is that
in the back of flap of the book so the
pictures that are in the book were
actually put in there by the publishing
company in terms of the the production
design of it and so that wouldn't I mean
that's not meant to be any particular
place it's just symbolic of Trump
rallies and
particularly the fact that there are so
many women in that image and as you can
see they're all very excited to see the
present there um and that was I suppose
you know one of the major discussion
points during the candidacy of Donald
Trump were these attitudes that he had
forced to have towards women the Access
Hollywood tape and all of that kind of
thing so I think they selected that
photograph for that reason just to
illustration one of the points in the
book because there is kind of a whole
chapter about female voters what about
the one in the beginning of the book
which is a much different kind of a
picture yeah and again that's one too to
illustrate I suppose the facts this
point I was making earlier about you
know that's quite a quite a bleak
photograph but I've see the gigantic
poster there of mr. Trump himself but
again to just highlight the fact that
I'm you know America isn't all these
wealthy cities that there are as vast
Suede's of the country in the middle in
the suburbs in smaller communities where
people just really felt they weren't
being listened to that their economies
their local economies we're plummeting
and no one was doing anything to help
about us and they turned to him for
salvation as a matter of fact if you go
back to your house top in your
introduction you talk about Cleveland I
want to read how you describe driving
into Cleveland you said is a city of
many sides driving in from the airport
you see the literal Rust Belt buildings
falling down once fabulous structures
crumbling a theme throughout this part
of the country there's graffiti there's
litter there are feral cats
there are mangy dogs and probably many
more vermin that are thankfully not
immediately apparent how often did you
see that in the United States frequently
and let me just stop asking do you see
that in Ireland yes you do I mean yeah
not not to the extent that I saw it in
parts of the u.s. though no and I mean
it just it was noteworthy
how desolate certain parts of the edges
of cities are you wouldn't see that in
Ireland at all and you know what was
insightful for me on that point was one
time in Pennsylvania where the mayor was
actually telling me in Monessen there he
can't afford to pull down crumbling
buildings so they remain as eyesores
because they just simply don't have
enough money in the coffers to take care
of those buildings so instead of it just
being a level grassy area you see these
crumbling structures and and you know
that that is not something that I would
have seen elsewhere
senator Reardon is that or just rude
they the Irish senator O'Riordan yeah
remember the Labor Party what does that
mean so we have a multi-party system in
Ireland and so we have several political
parties so late the Labour Party is one
of the parties there so we don't have
like Republican Democrat two sides like
this and the vast majority of our
parties are mostly centrist falling
slightly laughter right so the Labour
Party would be more tying itself into
the working man and woman the reason I
ask you this is back into November of
2016 where he makes a speech says some
very strong things on the Senate floor
and I want you to put this in context
how reflective is that of what you know
the Irish people to think so I don't
live in Ireland and I haven't lived
there for the last four years so I'm
probably not the best person to ask in
that regard and but you know there would
be split opinion there would be a lot of
people who would not be in favor of
President Trump there would be people
who are in favor of President Trump as
well and senator ridden there has been a
fairly vocal in his
dislike let's colors ever President
Trump and you know and others what would
share that same opinion as they would
here in the United States you know and
the division of opinion here it would be
the same in Ireland what did you notice
when you were out in these states and
covering the campaign about other media
people who would talk to you about their
own feelings because there as you know
there's a different image in this
country about the media than there has
been in years past
what would I take from what other
members of the media was what were they
saying to you privately did you know how
I mean it's well if someone says
something to me privately I don't mean I
want your names but I mean what kind of
things would they say to you about what
did they think of Donald Trump as you
went to the time again that you know I
mean again it's the range of opinion on
president Trump area is extraordinary
you know there are people who are very
fervent supporters of his and there are
people who really don't like him and
there's everything in between and you
know members of the media are human
beings as well and our voters I'm not a
voter in this country and so you know
they would have their own private
opinions as well and you know and it
would it would run the range there and
where I'm from as journalists like you
you just you can't have an opinion like
that you can't be a member of a
political party and work for RTE so um
you know I mean I but I'm not I wouldn't
be getting into us anyone had told me
over coffee or whatever you know that's
their own opinion okay you went to
Wisconsin yeah the cheese the butter
what did you learn about the butter well
I find it extraordinary that seemingly
some people in Wisconsin put butcher in
their teeth it's not something that we
would do in Ireland although we drink a
lot of tea Miche a lot of butter and but
yeah there was quite an odd situation
whereby Irish butter was banned in
Wisconsin because you know it's
America's Creamery America's Dairyland
so they have very strict
Galatians there in terms of regulating
for things are processed in all of that
so if Irish butcher had met the rigorous
high standards that there are in Ireland
and in line with EU regulations it
wasn't allowed in Wisconsin so there
were you'd meet these people who had to
travel over the border to Illinois to
buy their butter and essentially smuggle
it back in the the boot or the trunk of
their car so you know it's good to the
Irish products are so popular but it's
just another example of how states
differ so much in this country and there
are so many regulations to try and get
around in each place where you see more
regulation Ireland are here gosh well
I'm have seen on a regulations expert
but I think it depends on on the sector
and on the industry you know when it
comes to food products and that kind of
thing we have very different standards
there and in terms of the use of
antibiotics and hormones and all of that
kind of thing in food products and those
regulations would probably be a lot
higher in the European Union and but you
know I think yeah I I don't think I'm
the best place ever since I heard that
one back there was constant you met a
man named professor Mordecai Lee yeah
who is he
yes so he's a professor at the
University there in Milwaukee and a
native Wisconsin I am and I had a very
interesting chat with him about the you
know obviously Donald Trump won
Wisconsin it was one of the three states
that arguably gave him the White House
the others being Michigan and
Pennsylvania and and what I felt was
noteworthy was that Hillary Clinton
never campaigned in Wisconsin at all she
didn't go there even once and which I
thought it was interesting choice given
that you know if you're asking the
people of a state to vote for you you
should probably go there at least once
and Mordecai Lee the professor that you
mentioned he he disagrees with that
theory but and he was an interesting guy
just in terms of charging through how
different elections swing in Wisconsin
the people there hadn't
hadn't voted for a Republican since the
1980s in a presidential election and yet
they did this time can you explain this
from what you saw
and in those Wisconsin chapter you talk
about first those farmers view
Washington DC is totally disconnected
from their lives for them you actually
have to work to make a living work as in
hard physical and manual labor and
second referring to them as city people
in labor fancy people the average wage
in DC is $25 an hour and it's a
majority-black City just forty-four
percent of the population is white here
in Wisconsin the average wage is
seventeen dollars considerably below 87
percent of the population is white well
there may indeed be some fancy people in
DC most are not that's you saying that
but it doesn't matter the disconnect was
already there and draining the swamp
made it more real and this was an
argument that I heard not just in
Wisconsin but everywhere I went that
that slogan last president Trump out of
drain the swamp really resonated with
people and it's not a tale unique in
particular to the United States I think
you know in Ireland people would say oh
those ones up in Dublin or you know if
you take the European Union those people
over in Brussels or whatever there's
there's that common thing of wherever
the legislators are that they're
disconnected with the people that they
represent and that was something that
you know the president was very
effective in that campaign messaging and
it really seemed to strike with people
that they they would see their
representatives or their Senators you
know going off on the train or the plane
or whatever up to Washington DC in a
fancy suit and whatnot and they just
felt whatever they were doing there
wasn't helping them you know wasn't
helping them to get jobs and that they
weren't in touch with what was happening
to their lives specifically you write
statement reflects another part of
Donald Trump's messaging that was
borderline genius
if cartoonish and content drained the
swamp
yeah borderline genius how often did you
see that with him well I think I mean
you know we know he's he's a marketing
guru
really
reality TV star in his own right etc and
he knows how to use the media and get
messages across I mean he's done that
throughout his entire career and drained
the Swamper as three words is incredibly
evocative and it does what it says on
the tin you know immediately kind of
what he's talking about and I'll see
playing on that notion that DC was built
on a swamp and by training us taking out
the horrible people that lived there and
replacing it with better people and that
was something that you know whether
voters believed him or not or believed
that he could fulfill that or not they
were prepared to take a chance on us and
that was something that came up time and
time again that his messaging was
extremely powerful and resonated with
people you could go to Donald Trump
rally he might talk for 45 minutes I
mean he often talked spoke for very long
periods of time
and he you told him to photos afterwards
they wouldn't remember everything that
he said but they'd remember those chants
those mantras and that struck a chord
with them as something they really
wanted to hear and something that they
wanted to take a chance on that maybe if
that comes true things will be better
what was your reaction to the actual
vote tally on election night so I was
working right through the night it's
probably will were and particularly back
in Ireland there's a five hour time
difference so you're broadcasting
non-stop you know and I mean we have to
just stop and say obviously Hillary
Clinton did win the popular vote by
three million people and Donald Trump
won on the electoral college based on 70
artists and voters in three different
states so and you know I remember
broadcasting back home at one point and
I was waiting to do my live shot and I
can hear the panelists in studio and
they were saying oh no you know Hillary
Clinton might still have us here or
whatever and I was doing the mask oh no
you know I mean he had a hill to run up
and he ran up that hill you know the
electoral math was stacked against him
the polls were all trending in one
direction and so there is a challenge
there
he seemed to grab it and as we know
succeeded but based on your own coverage
in the way you saw the election were you
surprised
no no not remotely surprised I mean I I
had been saying on air for the couple of
weeks before thus don't discount Donald
Trump winning here it's not a clear-cut
clear-cut victory for Clinton and even
the polling ok was all trending in her
favor but actually by the time you got
to a few days a from polling day the
margin of error in certain places was
three and four percent on certain polls
and her victory margin was you know not
much more than that
so therefore that renders Appel really
not reliable and also a lot of the
sample sizes in the polling in this
country is only 1,000 people in Ireland
much smaller country it's 1,000 people
so high reliable is a poll of a thousand
people in a country that's large you
know and then you get into all the other
subsets of that in terms of is polling
being done on landlines who has
landlines versus mobile for cell phones
you know what native language they speak
when the pollster calls and all of that
so I think that the polling industry
probably got a bit of a whack last year
but just based on the people that I've
spoken to and and and where I'd been I
wasn't remotely surprised actually let
me ask you about being an anchor in
Ireland one of the more recent figures
we were aware of in this country when
Katie Couric was five-years CBS anchor
she was paid seventy five million
dollars reportedly is that the kind of
money that they pay in our no no no but
how do you not remotely I mean there
there's no there wouldn't be anyone
working in Irish media that's even paid
a million like you know it's not
comparable
what what what else is not comparable
about being an anchor in Ireland and in
the United States are you a star in
Ireland you would be very high-profile
yeah I mean you're you're beaming into
people's homes every evening when
they're having their dinner or whatever
at 6:00 p.m. and you know and we're a
much smaller country and we have far a
few
fewer TV stations than he would have
here do the anchors go out and make
speeches for money they can do yeah I
mean you have to get permission and all
of that from your bosses do you vote
when you're in the Irish media as a
private individual yes you do yeah yeah
and you have you did you vote all the
time yourself well so I would but since
I've lived in the u.s. we had a general
election and you can't vote from abroad
so I wasn't able to cast a vote for the
current dole dole air in the current
Parliament that's sitting there and in
that general election I was out of the
country and that's that where did you
grow up in Ireland I grew up in Dublin
in the capital city and just on the
south side and foothills of the Dublin
Mountains one of the kind of suburbs
just on the edge of the city there what
kind of a families you come from your
parents your other kids in the family
yeah so I'm the eldest of three girls
and both parents worked and working the
media or anything like that so I'm the
first one to really break through into
that sphere so through a lot of hard
graft as you know yourself and nothing
comes easy and in this life but
particularly if you want to get into
journalism in Ireland
you've got to work very hard and do all
your apprenticeships and all of that
kind of thing so I always wanted to be a
journalist since as far back as I can
remember I was writing poetry and novels
and did little mock radio show in my
bedroom with all that kind of stuff and
then went off to university and did my
undergraduate in journalism and then
after I guess seven or eight years after
graduation went back while working
full-time to a master's in international
relations part-time as well because I've
always been fascinated by world affairs
and geopolitics and all of that which is
why I wanted to come to Washington as a
foreign correspondent because you know
if you're into international affairs and
how the world works
this is really the center point of that
where did you go to school on Ireland I
went to school in a secondary school
called sanctuary College which was a
sisters
see all girls school and in Ireland
again it's different to hear the you
know most people go to public schools
and it is changing a little but mostly
they would be same sex schools
traditionally run by various religious
organizations so mine was just at the
end of my road and but despite that I
was late a lot even though my journey
about three minutes
when did the journalism kick in like I
mean as long as far back as I can
remember really like said I was I was a
small kid always writing stories and all
of that and just really fascinated with
how the world worked and if if something
was the rule or the regulation but why
is it like that and who makes those
rules and regulations and and what
happens in other countries you know
Ireland very small island nation with an
immigrant history so we're very outward
looking rather than inward looking we're
always looking to what's going on
elsewhere and maybe relations in America
or Australia or Europe or whatever so I
just a ferocious reader as well and as a
child and a teenager and just really
loved just broadcast journalism in
particular because of the immediacy of
us now a nice growing up there wasn't as
immediate as it is now a 24-hour news
cycle and everything's on your phone you
know and that was very much the era of
the one broadcast today or whatever but
and you know I just love that you get to
see so much happen in the world like we
get to have front seat to history as the
saying goes and that's an incredible
privilege to have as your job where did
you meet your husband
and he's a he's a he was a friend of a
friend but he's an incredibly private
person who doesn't work in the media and
doesn't like me talking about him in the
media so you have to keep some things
personal in this business you know did
he live here with you yeah
lift area yeah Annie's Irish yeah back
to the book the other states that you
went to like Kentucky Virginia North
Carolina which one of those do you
remember the most and why oh gosh that's
a hard question because and it's like
people are often asked me which states
do you like the best and you can't
answer that really because they're so
different you know and the Virginia I
will see is not too far from from
Washington DC and what always amazes me
is he can drive for half an hour and
you're in almost a different world and
which is true of all of the United
States
I love how diverse everywhere is in
terms of you know the architecture is
different the food is different the
makeup of the population is different
the accents there is a friend and
Kentucky is very like Ireland so I
really loved that and yeah the rolling
green hills you know like Lexington is
twinned with 30 well county kildare
which is horse mad as Lexington is you
know that would be the center of our
horse industry and lots of Irish people
in Lexington as well North Carolina
again beautiful for different reasons I
mean the beaches there are incredible I
was lucky enough to spend a bit of time
down around the Outer Banks as well
which is really stunning part of the
country who's Jason Meister in New York
yeah so Jason is a guy who is a local
organizer for the Trump campaign locally
in New York State there for their
primaries and then for the general as
well and he was you know by he would say
this himself all infra Donald Trump very
much of that wealthy Manhattan
background working in the real estate
industry he and his father would know
that Trump's for a long time
and he was you know he was really
charged with drumming up support for
Donald Trump in Manhattan which wasn't
an easy thing to do as we know we can
see from how he fared in the primaries
in the general in Manhattan but and you
know just he was a good example of
someone who you know the the wealthier
end of this country who were very big
supporters of Donald Trump in terms of
what he would do to deregulate the
financial industry pro-business reducing
taxes all of that and you know we've
seen some of that coming in already and
with the new tax law what's the American
dream
the American dream I mean I don't know
for Americans but for non-americans fair
and this is what I noticed traveling
around is like there is this insatiable
hope and optimism and positivity to do
better and that your kids will do better
than you did and your grandkids will do
better than you did and when you travel
to America this is the American dream
that's what you hear people describing
to you and you know one person I met I
had had said how you know she was the
first person in her family to finish
high school and she was going to make
sure that her son was the first person
to finish university and she would do
everything she had to do to make sure
that he could be a doctor be a lawyer be
whatever he wanted to be and I think
people are always striving for that and
it's not happening right now in the u.s.
I mean the census statistics show that 3
out of 5 people are the same level of
income and wealth as they were in 2008
like that's quite a substantial period
of time to not be making slight
improvements on your life and and I felt
that people I met particularly those who
had been Democratic voters and Renee's
siding with Donald Trump was they felt
they've been somehow left behind that
they weren't going to retire or die
better off than their parents were and
they weren't going to be able to give a
better life to their children and that
kind of goes against that thinking that
I think is in this spirit
so love Americans what is your reaction
when you hear our politicians say or
even our public say America is the
greatest country in the world I think
you know many people in their own
countries say that in Ireland we say
it's the greatest country in the world
well you know and I mean in many ways
America is is great you know why else do
so many people go through so much to
come here and make a better lot try and
make a better life for themselves and
you know I think and there have been
surveys to back this up in the last few
months that maybe that reputation that
viewpoint is diminishing now and by
virtue of recent policies here things
like not going along with pretty much
every other country on Earth in terms of
the Paris climate record and you know
policies towards the Middle East perhaps
so you know but I think Americans are
entitled to say they're the greatest
country it's the greatest country in the
earth but but so can every other nation
so looking back on your experience of
the four years and looking back on your
work on this book if when you go home
and somebody says to you describe to me
very briefly why the people that voted
for Donald Trump voted for him what
would you say what are the main reasons
I would say there are a couple of
reasons one is he said he would bring
back that American Dream and make life
better for them and that he would change
things up in Washington again the drain
the swamp improved things there and also
because he kind of he didn't stand for
anything in particular he could stand
for anything that you wanted him to
stand for and ultimately a lot of people
are single issue voters but he was
listening to them he said he would fix
the economy and bring back jobs and
ultimately that's what everyone wants in
life you know they want to be able to
provide for themselves and their
families as best they can and if you
feel beaten down you will take a chance
on someone that's offering you something
new so last question to you if you ever
had to come back to the United States
and live again and had a choice which
state would you live in that's the hard
question again I would love to come back
to DC again but again with the job that
I have that you can get out of the
bubble that is the city and travel
around if I was going to check out of
life totally I mean the beaches in
California are pretty amazing and you
know like say Kentucky also a fabulous
place really like Texas I can't I don't
think I could em I have the I've had the
best of both worlds here I've got to
live in a city that lives on politics
which I do but I've got to travel around
every week and visit almost every other
state in this country and meet the great
people and experience what there is to
offer the name of the book is in America
tales from Trump country our guest has
been Katrina Perry and we thank you very
much thanks Bryan